[Music]
he's been called the prodigy the savior
of the French scene that is unbelievable
from the young Frenchmen of wounded
crime with a heart of gold and an
absolute demon with the oppened server
first he's had enough he's gonna keep
going do it just who in the hell is I
would the 18 year old phenom took over
the world of Counter Strike in 2018 but
a lot of people started taking notice as
I won 2017 when he entered different
online ladders and leagues and one of
those was FPL a staging ground for
up-and-coming talent to play with
established pros and the opportunity to
be scouted by pro teams and as you can
probably guess he immediately began
destroying everyone his style of play
reminds me a lot of like Kenny SR simple
it's full of movement and aggressive
pressure that forces you to make
mistakes it's incredibly tough to pull
off almost like prototype dubs-y we
finish yourself a 3k his mechanical
brilliance and game sense force people
to pay attention as he ran his way
through FPL what is close every single
time he enters the server win or lose
this dude is having fun take his
reported decision to turn down $15,000 a
month to play with envious in order to
finish school he was only 17 when he
made that call or the decision to pick
up the OP all because nobody on against
all authority wanted to do it Naphtali
freaks adult disc balls dude everything
that makes xyu special is a result of
his unbridled love for counter-strike
counter-strike still just a game push to
get it it's good he's playing with the
headshot angle there's a chance here
in dominating the online circuits his
presence became a bit of a myth he had
to be cheating they said hmm I mean even
g2 allegedly passed on the young prodigy
because certain players on the team
thought he was cheating one of the first
guys thinking that he was cheating like
well move because I used to play him
back in the the lower tier oh I see and
it's not until you actually play with
him and speak to him that you understand
that the guy just doesn't see things the
same way as we do imagine and his brain
is just like the matrix so you got
numbers coming down like okay he was
here at one point so he could be here
here here and then he just checks those
two angles and he's in one of them and
he kills them that's how that's how it
feel good but none of that mattered
because at 18 zero had his pick of teams
to sign with he ultimately chose
vitality a French org looking to build a
championship winning team around the
young superstar and despite playing for
a team where he's their best player by a
goddamn country mile the pressure of
creating a career in an industry where
careers don't last that long
hasn't set in yet now xyu isn't just
another pub star who made the transition
to the parolees this dude
leaves other pros floor oh he's so
gifted that even simple the best
individual player in all of
counter-strike took notice and the
craziest part is he's only 18 and
psywave what is it like being in front
of this amazing crowd
so we're gonna have it to you guys out
of that and look this is a world that
rewards personality but instead of being
held back by his introverted vibe xyu
continues to shrug off the status quo in
fact it's hilariously chiming sigh wait
I'm out of few words
what have you got to say about winning
this game and despite his shyness xyu
isn't fazed by a stadium full of fans
established veterans don't shake his
confidence whether it's simple or device
he's still gonna take your head off
given the slightest opportunity despite
vitality bombing it or the recent Berlin
major was I will put up a great
individual performance great how's that
making a good go of this Zoe was cool
off in love but I don't think he's the
one that's caught off they're locked in
here with him and that's huge I do not
come to love he doesn't care whether or
not he's the savior French CS Tazawa
those conversations don't matter
you didn't really read like that kind of
stuff he's in his own world for sure he
doesn't like if you could tell him like
he's an idiot or he's the best friend of
world and it just like he would have a
savory actually doesn't care I think he
definitely knows how good he is but he
doesn't doesn't like to show off or
anything he's just like yeah just
laid-back and he'll do what he needs to
do for team what matters is his ability
to present us with amazing feats of
Counter Strike every flick who wants to
kill there's the head she'll pull the
back better than your boots always got
the triple every crazy clutch every time
his love of the game leads to something
incredible zai was saying the only thing
that needs to be said and damned if that
isn't beautiful
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification fell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages